where we are at this moment is yet
another confluence of I would have to
say on all sides fanatical religious
conflict and I don't think that it's
possible for the United States to as a
country to detach itself from a
fanatical religious tradition which
which is engaged in in this situation
and in terms of grand historical forces
it's a replay of things that have gone
back many many years and interestingly
enough to me because I wrote a piece for
the 50th anniversary of Israel where I
went to Israel in and actually tried to
learn as much as I could about what was
happening there but it's centering on
the same part of the world again that's
so often it has Palestine and Jerusalem
and the Crusades
and the various occupations by all three
of three forces are almost like a short
history of the world you could argue
that the people with the most impact on
the course of history are the ones who
commit the the worst deeds because then
tremendous numbers of other other people
wind up with their lives completely
co-opted trying to deal with the
consequences so i guess it was quite a
stir years ago when hitler was man of
the year on Time magazine but but that
was I think a historically inaccurate
representation but you know evil or you
let's just say nefarious purposes are
willing to use much more radical and
damaging means than say a monk who was
going out to help the poor well if you
ask that question you know the end of
the 19th century I think everyone would
have said yes of course we're doing
better we're don't we don't have slavery
now so much and we seem to be behaving
more tolerant Lien's of with but then
was the Holocaust I think the the real
legacy of the Holocaust is that you we
can no longer we can no longer think of
a trajectory you know of towards in
light of an Enlightenment trajectory
because what I of course the way I have
to read the Holocaust is that the
country where I've for which I have the
most perhaps artistic respect because
because Bach essentially raised me as a
musician this extraordinarily developed
country was at the
the heart of this this outer utter
calamity and probably the most
culturally of sophisticated development
that we have ever achieved and also a
country which had achieved the most
sophisticated integration of various
racial and national types there was no
country in Europe and for instance in
which Jewish people were more accepted
into high station and important
professions and then you had the camps
so I would say finding the overarching
purpose or if we are to take that to
mean as it often does some development
in a positive way about human nature I
think it's very very tenuous and hard to
hard to believe I think one has to
believe much more in individual kindness
and and daily decency and much less
grand ideas